- [Shannon] Hi, I'm
Shannon from Khan Academy.
And I want to show you
how to make the most
of your learning time on
Official SAT Practice.
Research has shown that more time spent
on Official SAT Practice is associated
with greater SAT scores,
but how you spend that
time really matters.
Before we begin, let's make
sure you know how to access
Official SAT Practice.
Make sure you're signed into
your Khan Academy account
by checking for your name in
the upper right-hand corner.
If you're using Official
SAT Practice in a class,
you should see a tab that says SAT
on the left side navigation.
Select the SAT tab and
from there select Practice
to be taken to your student dashboard.
If you aren't using SAT
practice in a class,
you can select Edit
Courses to add the SAT tab
to your Khan Academy account.
Number one. Link your
account to CollegeBoard.
To receive a personalized practice plan,
you have two options.
Number one, take a series
of diagnostic quizzes.
Or number two, link your
CollegeBoard account
to Khan Academy.
The easiest way to get a study plan
that is personalized to
your results is to link
your Khan and CollegeBoard accounts.
Once your accounts are linked,
we'll automatically recommend skills
where you have room to improve,
especially ones that show
up frequently on the SAT.
We recommend that you link your accounts
so that you can waste no time
improving the right skills.
Number two.
Follow your personalized
practice recommendations.
If you already linked your Khan Academy
and CollegeBoard accounts,
you will see your skill
recommendations on the Practice tab.
At the top of the page,
you should see a set
of recommended practice for
math and reading and writing
that always end in a timed mini section.
Now, let's take a deeper look
at how skills are recommended.
Let's say there are two skills
at two different levels.
Skill A is at level two,
skill B is that level three.
You might think it would be more important
to improve skill A.
However, in some cases, we may recommend
that you practice skill B
because it shows up more
frequently on the SAT
and improving it to
level four would do more
to raise your score.
Number three. Level up skills.
In official SAT practice, you
have a specific skill level
for the 41 skills in math
and the 28 skills in reading and writing.
As you answer questions, your
skill levels move up or down
depending on how you do.
Leveling up your skills shows you
that you are consistently advancing
in the content on the SAT.
And it's a great way to
monitor your progress.
You might be wondering,
"But what if I do if I
get stuck on a skill?"
It's normal to feel stuck at times
when studying for the SAT.
We've all been there.
But those moments of
confusion are also the times
when you have the opportunity
to improve your score the most.
Push through by using the
hints, instructional videos
or ask for help when you're
learning a new skill.
As you answer questions
on Official SAT Practice,
you have access to text
explanations and videos
to deepen your understanding
of the content.
You can also use the Review
tab to review your answers
from completed practice.
If you're still stuck, reach
out to one of your classmates,
a teacher or a family member for support.
Number four. Take a
full-length practice test.
Select the Full Tests tab at the top
to access the full-length
SAT practice tests.
Taking a practice test is a crucial step
to ensure you're prepared for a test day
by simulating the real test experience.
Eight full-length practice
tests are available
on Official SAT Practice,
which can be taken in one sitting
or section by section over time.
The information from your full-length test
will also result in even
more personalized practice.
Now that you know the
top four tips to using
Official SAT Practice,
you're ready to get started.
Log into your Khan Academy account today.
Happy studying!